ehi c'è nessuno si sono dimenticati di
me
qua sotto c'è nessuno fatemi uscire da
qui oggi a grandissima richiesta di
amgas anche voi avrete del meta più
durante questo video quindi state bene
attenti alla fine del video scoprirete
se avete visto anche voi funziona ogni
turno scopriremo se siamo impostori o
piume e chi vince potrà pescare dal
mistery box invece di avere le mister
ibex questa volta abbiamo un ambiente
reebok è per noi dovremo mettere labaro
dentro pescara indossato misterioso ma
non posso pescare ancora chi vince potrà
pescare dalla mister hip hop
mettetevi comodi proietti pop corn è
iniziato con il credito
diamo il nostro ruolo io non ci sono
celeste invece vitale al sole e merlino
è giallo arancione giallo devono
scappare dall imposta ore 10 del rio del
momento di scegliere la mia arma resta
perché troppo divertente da tirare in
testa a vita andiamo a cercarlo trovato
nascondiglio perfetto o cordate
forse è meglio subito un cappello sono
riuscito per niente giallo roma
giallo preso ora mi resta arancione
sarei accorta siamo qui ha preso tanto
ma non ho trovato lui si sta cercando
ancora non si vede ma cosa sta facendo
così si è visto
c'è qualcosa di strano laggiù guardate
avete visto c'è qualcosa da giu l'ho
trovato in astuzia giusti fredda
no non c è nessuno ha lasciato il
cappello
no mi hai fregato meritato una trappola
dove pescare dalla miste i bot
non vedo l'ora di mettermi questa classe
di essere feroci perfino il geloso ne
vorrebbe nelle casse di el harchi fa non
si staranno benissimo queste casse di
hello kitty the show e vuole merlino la
casa di hello kitty
secondo round prima trask per voi di che
colore è vitale senza andare a rivedere
vediamo se siete stati attenti ripetero
nei commenti berlino e il caldo e la
lingua di fuori
prati e peschiamo
e arrivato il momento per me di
scegliere la via arma quale centro quale
scelto quale scelto sceglierò hanno
dimenticato
ho cambiato il cappello vedete quel
cappello con le ricette adesso così
posso dare più veloce mi nasconderò
dentro alla macchina e mi chiuderò a
chiave così l'impostore non potrà
prendermi sono in macchina o rami chiuso
a chiave
anche se l'impostore mi trova non potrà
prendermi perché sono chiusa a chiave
fatichiamo clima semi trova posso vedere
tutto guardatela giu ma chi sta facendo
sta rincorrendo gli uccelli
ancora non mi ha vista equa ma dove
giallo giallo sta scappando
sembra che sia giallo che sta
rincorrendo l'impostore cose date stanno
giocando fino accorgerà secondo voi che
sono qua dentro alla macchina
mi dispiace per te chiosa non puoi
prendermi è meglio che te ne vai
ciao ciao ciao ciao tanto non puoi
prendermi sto provando aprire le porte
di dietro ma la macchina è tutta chiusa
poi prendermi ciao ciao hai perso
impostore che rientra non ha ancora
perso perché per perdere io dovrei
tornare dentro e cambiare il colore
della lampada crew mail ma perché si
allontani così posso uscire dalla
macchina e scappare
9 dispiace per te ma è tutto aiuta la
macchina o troppo caldo devo
assolutamente uscire dalla macchina
impostare si è allontanato non riesco a
vedere come forse il momento giusto per
uscire
speriamo che non stia tendendo una
trappola via libera andiamo
è stata una passeggiata scritta ma che
partita a vita
siamo anche da poco ma che ci fai
ammiro trasformato il mostro vita perché
un bel pescare dalla mistery box vediamo
che cosa resti qua c'è qualcosa di molto
morbido un altro paio di calze no sembra
che per fortuna merlino è rimasto pure
in giardino perché berlino vuole sempre
strano mega che però cercano in mille
pezzi e bellissimo passiamo ora al terzo
round nuota in più per voi lasciate un
mi piace a questo video entro due
secondi gareggiano mi raccomando il
giallo detta mangiare l'etichetta
vediamo un po di coda pescato
voleva mandarmi l'amaro assaporato i bar
l'imposta dormendo è un po tacco
qui posso requisito di schiacciare un
pisolino come l'impostore stato armeno a
propiziare la chiama nasconte c senza
essere b io mi nascondo qui così marino
non mi troverà
ciao
ok siamo nascosti a quanto pare non ci
trova in arrivo finora non ci ho visto
ma non appena si allontana possiamo
tornare dentro e cambiare il colore
delle lampade così avremmo vinto
arrivato l'avviso merlino ha vinto
vedremo che cosa sceglie una cosa puoi
scegliere per lì non mangiare tutto
vediamo che cosa peso mieli ne ho preso
un pre mito del grano chiare de felici
quarto e ultimo round vai perché
arancioni
vediamo quale arma scelgo ragazze ho
avuto un'idea su per pazza per questo
nascondino
guardate questo scatto non so se
riuscita a vederlo quell enorme le volta
quasi quanto me mi nasconderò dentro a
questa scatola poi metterò l'erba finta
sopra non penso che riuscirò mai a
trovarmi nel posto re
vediamo se funziona ecco qua la scatola
gigante mi raccomando berlino non dire
niente al impostore
no non dire al impostare che sono come
no berlino davvero
i ragazzi sono ufficialmente sotto terra
quindi non penso che l'impostore
riusciva mai a trovarmi questo è
decisamente il nascondino più strano ed
estremo che abbia mai fatto per fortuna
entrano degli spiragli di luce da sopra
così riuscita a vedermi bene ma per
quanto tempo debba restare nascosto e
quale tornare ma l'impostore non è
ancora uscito a cercarmi dietro un vaso
nemmeno ei c'è nessuno si sono
dimenticati di me
qua sotto c'è qualcosa di strano sembra
morbido c'è nessuno
fatemi uscire da qui un fa non riesco
proprio a trovarla dove si sarà nascosta
nel frattempo mi sono seduto su questa
cosa strana qui su questo strano
rialzamento del terreno è sempre molto
poco tra l'altro mi riposo qui un po
perché così pesante non riesco più ad
aprirlo c'è nessuno o no è ora che pozzo
[Musica]
la vesco più ad aprire la scatola è
troppo pesante ci sia qualcosa sopra c'è
nessuno tu sei accorta berlino devo
chiamare berlino pervenire stampare
berlino berlino viene tra il parma e
berlino sento qualcuno forse qualcuno si
sta avvicinando e io scappo questa pone
così ferma cavi per avermi liberato dal
mio nacco dibattito a scappare
e va bene ha vinto questa volta ha vinto
andiamo a pescare dalla nostra vista
rimbalzo per quello che è curioso
un'altra capsula dei fortunati di harry
potter libera dagli scarti nascondini
abbiamo trovato altri due personaggi
vediamo che troviamo qua io spero sempre
di trovare harry e hermione od raro
vediamo provate a indovinare voi con gli
indizi che personaggio è prima di aprire
il personaggio anche melo lino e molto
incuriosito primo indizio è cosa questa
è una lampadina
io vedo l'immagine del leone quindi
grifondoro secondo indizio questo devo
bagnarlo per vedere cosa c'è scritto
ecco qua è comparso questo incantesimo e
pisti per una idea di che incantesimo
sia apriamo la bacchetta vediamo perché
sembra un ombrello pure la ambrì
portogallo è sicuramente hagrid perché
questa è la torta che adri da ha r vi
ricordate abbiamo qua il libro dei
mostri quindi sicuramente agri e qua
abbiamo punto il cagnolino nero tra
l'altro ad ride il personaggio preferito
di vitali se avete completato tutte le
tasche avete visto anche voi li lascia
allegri mitici nei commenti qual è stata
la vostra sorpresa ho preferito della
mistery box
volete un altro episodio di nascondino
mondo e pallone le sorprese più belle mi
piace ora vi lasciamo poi quattro
cartelle riga cui cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video i casi su quello che
preferite
buona visione